prices and inefficiencies in the data
markets take it away you have until 10
to 50.
thanks very much for your advice uh so
I'm going to talk about too much data
prices and inefficiencies in data market
this is a joint work with
zaggler and Annie maximum who is in the
audience and if you have any questions
they can ask you
um okay so the motivation of this talk
is the fact that we know our lives are
much better by using the technologies
that are around so we can like Lively
broadcast this talk because of the
technology and we regularly use these
products we do not even bother uh
worrying about why they're using these
products we're using Facebook Twitter
talking about it proudly
um so these applications and products
are founded and funded by data what do I
mean by that
so there every day they're being
improved by the data that are gathered
from us
as the users and uh they're becoming a
higher quality technology and at the
same time their revenue is generated by
our data so basically by the
advertisements or by explicitly selling
uh data they are generating Revenue
so now the heavy usage of the data in
the recent years brought the public
awareness about like the privacy issues
and the scandals around it so in
particular the Cambridge analytica data
Scandal was one of the famous ones who
made the public become aware of like the
issues of the privacy
and the questions regarding the the
regulation that should be and whether
there should be laws around the Privacy
so in particular if you were also
listening to the uh uh Mark Zucker
Zuckerberg going to the Congress one of
the question that was going around was
that what is the appropriate model for
the data market
uh so in order to answer that question
some things we should understand about
the data market and what are the
features of the data that makes it
unique so one of the features is that
the first fact is that there's no
unified definition of the privacy and in
fact the people are not aware of how
much value they have for the privacy and
on top of that how their data is going
to be used and by whom they are going
it's going to be used and at the same
time the third factor which will be the
focus of the stock is the fact that
actually there is a high correlation
among the data of different people so
even if you do not want to share your
data if some other people that are
correlated with you are sharing their
data probably some information about you
without your consent will be leaked
uh so in this talk I'm going to actually
focus on let me make sure that this is
yes I'm going to focus on this third
bullet so we would like to understand
how this correlation will affect the
equilibrium prices
and in particular sorry in particular we
would like to know whether there are any
uh equilibrium that are beneficial for
both the user and also the platform
and what are the implications of these
markets for the personal data so if you
have a data market how would this affect
the users and the platform and how can
they improve it so the main question is
whether we should treat privacy as an
economic good like a commodity just no
normal market for Commodities or whether
we should actually put regulations and
actually treat it as a right not as
something that you want to sell
so uh what I'm going to do in this talk
we are going to talk about a very simple
model of data sharing so this is a
stylized model of data sharing uh by one
user where when you are sharing your
data some relevant data about the others
will be also revealed and we assume that
the platform wants to buy the data uh
from the users in order to infer the
type of the users
uh we basically first established some
we first established some information
information measure and then study the
equilibrium existence of this game
uh after having the existence we are
going to characterize the equilibria and
also the efficiency properties of this
we are going to provide the conditions
on the rich the equilibria will be
efficient or inefficient and uh we then
look at the generalization of course
then for example you have competition
when you have multiple platforms then
you have when your values are unknown to
the platforms or when you're even the
correlation Matrix is not completely
known
at the end of the talk after learning
more about the equilibrium we are going
to see what are the schemes that we can
use in order to regulate this market and
what are the possible approaches
okay so there is a large literature
which I'm not going to dive into but uh
if I want to categorize it I will
actually say that one main category is
the related literature in the Privacy
which is in the law literature as well
as in the so it's going back to ages ago
into law literature and also it's in the
economics literature uh there is also
the information Market
uh that's where you are basically
selling and buying the data and then
there are like some uh if you want to
look at the externalities I would say
that the early articles are going back
to the McCarthy and Fairfield and Engel
so these articles are basically talking
about the externalities and some more
recent works on the data externality and
information
Market are this paper so I'm not going
to dive into the details of these papers
for the sake of time so let me jump into
the model
so we assume that we have any user these
are the data holders that are residing
on a network
and each user has a personal type so for
example you're you have a personal
preference of political affiliation okay
so this is your type I will denote it by
x i this is coming from a gaussian
distribution
and users types are correlated with each
other so this correlation is going to be
represented by matrix Sigma
and as a platform what you want to learn
is this excess so you want to learn the
types of the users
so how can you do that you're going to
offer a price and in exchange for that
price what you will get back from the
users there is some data so what is that
data and how is it related to the type
so data is Si which is a noisy version
of your type for example in your profile
you are going to actually like some
pages those are not exactly your
affiliation but they are going to
actually say something about your type
so s i is going to be the data that will
be shared by you in exchange for a price
sorry does the network have any role
Beyond if you go back
um
meaning Beyond just being the
correlations in Sigma okay you're just
insistence and you're not making any
assumptions that the sigmas are zero one
is just an arbitrary correlation yeah
so you will you I will explain the
actions in the exercise yeah uh the way
Sigma appears is uh Sigma inverse in the
likelihood of X so should I be thinking
of the network as Sigma inverse or the
support of Sigma inverse or the support
of Sigma
um so the these are the this is the
covariance Matrix uh among the types so
what so it's just the covariance Matrix
okay and like the you have like XIs and
the covariance Matrix that shows the
correlation among them is defined by
this Sigma
I have two questions
do you have this data that they give
does it have a single observation of X
Factor
uh a single observation as I I mean yes
you will have one as well and then uh
the second question is Doles like edges
are just uh
there to reflect that there is yeah this
is just to represent so it's not really
like the network social network it is
the correlation Matrix that's that's all
okay
so are there zeros when there's no Edge
and then the last question is are the
zi's also going to be correlated or
they're no no they're independent the
noise
so zi I didn't write it in this slide so
GI is an independent noise
okay
okay now we have the now let's actually
see now that we know what is the type of
the user and the data let's see what you
can do in this network we are assuming
that the only action you can take is
whether you want to share or not to
share so you reside on there you're you
everybody's on the Facebook let's assume
and you you have this you have the
option of like whether you want to let
your data to be shared by the like uh
data for with some application on
Facebook or not so we are denoting the
action of sharing by AI
so if this is whether you want to share
your personal data and the set of the
users who are sharing their data on the
platform I'm going to show it with the
calligraphic S of a okay so these are
the people who are actually those are
the data datas that are shared on the
platform so this is what the platform
will see
so now we are reaching to the part that
I want to Define what is my like what is
this data that the platform is gathering
right or what is this information that
I'm getting from you so I will Define it
as the reduction in the mean square
error
okay so at the beginning I have like for
example Sigma a square and then when the
people are sharing their data and I'm
sharing my data there will be a
reduction in my estimator so this minus
Square the reduction in the mean square
error is the leaked information of the
user eye okay so this is the part this
is your part that you will care about
your privacy so this is the part that
will show up in your utility as well as
the part that will show up in the
platform's utility as you will see so
just to
give you an example it's possible that
for example you do not share your data
but some information will be leaked
right because there is a correlation
right so here you can see that agent one
decided not to share so A1 is 0 and 2
and 3 are sharing and since there is a
correlation between one and two and one
and three some information will be
leaked
now let me also Define the payoff so
your payoff as the platform will be what
it will be like you care about the total
leakage so if you have higher total
leakage you will have a higher utility
so it would be the summation of leakage
over all individuals and you are going
to pay a price for buying those data so
minus the prices that you paid
now the payoff like the user how do we
Define that so as a user you have a
value for privacy so I will denote that
value that you have for privacy by Vi
so if you share your data I'm going to
pay a price so the platform is giving
you Pi but some information about you
will be leaked so you're going to lose
some value VI times the leaked
information so this is your utility if
you share your data and if you do not
share your data you do not get any price
back
and some information will be leaked
about you so it would be minus VI
multiplied by the leaked information so
you can see the difference of these two
is just that you are also taking this
action one so this information leakage
is potentially higher here right
um and if I want to look at the set plus
the Surplus is the summation of the I
will consider the summation of the
platform and all the users uh in the
word together so that would be my social
surplus so if I sum up we can see that
the prices will cancel out and what is
left is the summation of 1 minus v i
times the leaked information so that
would be my social surface
so so far these are just the definitions
now let's actually jump into the
definition more definition so let's
actually also look at the solution
Concepts so uh the user equilibrium is
defined as an action AI which maximizes
your utility
considering the actions of all other
agents so of course this could be uh for
a given price Vector this could be not
unique right depending on the actions of
the others you can also have another
equilibrium so we are going to denote
the set of old user equilibrium
corresponding to a price vector by
calligraphic AP okay
now we will show actually uh a few
properties of this information leakage
that we Define so the first property we
call it the submodularity so basically
what it means is that as more users are
going to share their information the
marginal leakage is going to be
decreased
so you can see that you can assume that
like when people are sharing their
information something will be known
about you so when you are sharing uh
more data that will the margin will
actually have a less effect a smaller
effect so we call this sub modularity so
let's actually look at this example and
effect of the submodularity so consider
the price Vector P1 P2 MP3 and suppose
that at the beginning agent 2 decided to
share while agent 3 decided not to share
at this point potentially agent 1 may
not share
now if you have this uh submodularity
property
if two and three both of them will share
now it can happen that one will be now
willing to share why because the
marginal leakage that you will provide
by sharing is going to be decreased and
as a result you may actually now be
willing to get P1 right so as a result
this is like the implication of the sub
modularity so if the larger set of the
users decide to share then I will be
more willing probably to share right and
it probably reminds you of the super
modular games which we will see in the
next slide
I don't really understand that you what
you said in words make sense to me but
what's written there
I guess the marginal increase in what
marginal increase of information be kept
so you if you share the marginal the
marginal information leakage will
increase right yeah this I function uh
it's it's going to be increased by an
extra share right now suppose that is a
superset of Agents will share right now
again if you share this marginal will
increase but this increase is less right
so that was bad so that is a sub
modularity and this is also you can see
it in this example so if two people are
sharing now if I share I know that my
information I will share extra
information but this shared extra
information is lower than in this
situation so as a result I will be
willing to get P1 okay
and yes
exactly exactly so but still you will be
submergible right it could be less
effective but still it will not be the
other way around right so uh and this is
this is a particular property I wouldn't
say that it is for any sort of
information leakage but for the mean
square root uh it holds and also for
some other uh interestings yes
so from the perspective of the platform
there's a decreasing marginal returns
from buying information
and so from the literature of you know
the the complexity organ cavity of the
value of information we know plenty of
counter examples right where we
see that little information might not be
useful once you get a certain amount it
becomes worth
and so those would be
don't be instances of information models
where the monotonicity will go the other
direction so that's actually very
interesting yes I agree so for this
model then we have the monetary city as
usual and the sub modularity but as you
as you mentioned it's not without loss
of generality it's not about any
solution concept and any distribution
assumption
uh so and then the other property that
we can see here is monotonicity so
probably monotonicity holds the
submodularity is the case the Palmetto
so monotony city of the information
leakage it means that if more people are
sharing the more information will be
revealed about you so this is a very
natural property now having these two
properties
as you can guess we can see that the
user equilibrium exists in fact the set
of the user equilibria forms a complete
lattice and it is not empty and it has
the largest and smallest element
and the proof idea as you could see in
the previous example and you could guess
is that we said that the leaked
information is submodular or in other
words our game will be a super modular
game so as a result we can use the task
explain theorem to show that it it has a
lattice structure and Smalls and
sorry
so it has a so you can Define the joint
and the Max and mean action on any two
elements of that so for they have for
every two equilibrium we can Define it
Max and mean and for all of them there
exists and then there will be a unique
maximum unique minimum
foreign
equilibrium so this is for the user
equilibrium given a price Vector now as
the platform you are supposed to choose
the prices and the people are supposed
to act on it so the the notation of the
equilibrium that we will use is the
stackelberg equilibrium where the uh an
action profile a and a price Vector p is
a stackable if first of all the actions
are belonging to the user equilibrium
set and moreover the utility that the
platform gets on that action profile is
the highest among all uh potential
actions in that user profile and
potential prices
so this is like the highest that the
platform could get out of the user Club
a possible user
is that clear
any questions yes
this is like sender preferred if you
want to say this is like the sender
preferred in the
information design literature
[Music]
okay so now
uh when we know that the user
equilibrium exists this one of course
exists because it's a maximum right so
uh for any Sigma and V the secular group
is cycleberg equilibrium exists
okay so now we have the existence now we
should actually see what are the
properties of this equilibrium okay
are you also making a selection that is
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yeah and
that's why I said that of course it
exists because I take the maximum right
um any questions
okay
so now let's actually before I uh jump
into some real properties let's actually
go over a few examples together so the
first thing I want to see is that
whether the total payment monoton in the
set of the users who will share their
information
so let's actually start with a very
simple example you have two users
everything is symmetric they have the
same value and there there's a
correlation of row among them
so uh if I want to draw the user
equilibrium as the function of the price
vectors we are going to have a figure
like this so we have four regions
so in the blue region both so when the
two prices both of them are high both
users will share then both prices are
low nobody will share if one of the
prices is high the other one is low then
one of the users will share and you can
see that there is an overlap between
these two regions of course right
because we have multiplicity for each
price
okay now so far so good now let's
suppose that I'm actually going to
increase so the correlation among the
two users okay so as I'm increasing the
correlation this region becomes bigger
right at the lower price you're willing
to both share your data right so at some
point what will happen is that this is
the price the the price that will
actually we will pay to the same price
on this line I'm paying the same price
to both of the users at the same time
right so when I'm getting to this line
what I can see is that so at this point
uh I'm paying the same prices here and
both users will share let's actually
increase a little with the correlation
more so now what I can see is that at
this point I can in fact get an
equilibrium where both users will share
in this region right and at this price
before while when the price was higher
sorry when the price was
higher like this
at this price I could not get both of
them share right so you can see a
non-monotonicity in there if I like the
two top in the total payment right so
here I'm having a lower total payment
while both of the users will share my
equilibrium okay so this is one thing
that we can see
and the other example is we would like
to see whether the Surplus has any sort
of monotonicity whether increasing or
decreasing in terms of the value that
you have for the Privacy so
again consider that two user example so
what we can see in the second Burger
equilibrium is that actually the Surplus
will have a shape like this so what
happens is that if the values of the
user is very low in particular less than
one where one is the value of the
platform for the data
then the Surplus is positive and as you
increase the value the Surplus is going
to decrease so it's going to decrease
until here now when you pass one still
it's gonna decrease and it's becoming
impact negative in this region
uh until some threshold when your value
is higher than something then both users
decide not to share anymore because
their value is sufficiently high and
then all of a sudden it becomes a zero
right so you can see that again it's not
either increasing or decreasing so
these are just two examples so now let's
see whether we can say anything
meaningful like any sort of uh
results so yes go ahead
if the platform approached them and
so
here the prices are given simultaneously
so instead if I could approach one user
and then
make them a take a really good offer out
of price
and approach the second user afterwards
that's probably so improve based on
better
so since I'm taking the highest
equilibrium I'm not sure if it's gonna
improve it right yeah so that's what I'm
wondering is it is the highest
equilibrium
because people get away from right so
some like if I had a sequence of people
somebody in the middle
has a different choice in the second
problem that they do in the max
yeah it's not obvious I would guess that
actually the highest one is doing better
than this one if I go sequentially uh so
I want to convince them one by one
depending on the notion of the
equilibrium that you want to Define for
the sequence
uh but I don't think that you can do
better than that because you get all the
external all the possible externalities
from others
so for example I can convince both of
them to share at a zero price right well
if I go sequentially
for the first one if I want to ask them
to share it depends on how I want to
unless I want to look at the
simultaneous Move games I don't think
that they will share right so I can
actually deplete the price to zero
the correlation is sufficiently high now
if I want to go sequentially it's not
clear for me whether they will share in
the first round
so
I guess I still know that the other
person will share in a second so it's so
it will be like simultaneous then yeah
so but that's a very good question I
haven't thought about it to pin it down
so
I think this might be weird
that your way of doing it sequentially
but uniquely selected after you need
something imperfect
actually yes that's a very good point
because also uh it will be easier to
justify and explain right so
um thanks thanks very much
uh okay so uh now
let's actually look at the see whether
we can do any characterization so the
first thing we will do is that we're
doing the easiest thing press
characterization so suppose that I know
who I want to share let's see whether I
know I can pin down what will be the
price that I should offer so the price
that I should offer to an agent to share
if I want them to share should make them
indifferent between sharing and not
sharing right that's the best thing I
can do so as a result the price that I
will offer is the the difference of the
leakage if you share multiplied by their
value for privacy okay
now the question is that what is this
value or can we say anything based on
the Matrix properties so let's actually
call the information leakage that is
caused by others that for others means
that if you do not share and the others
decide to share let's call that the
network effect
so what we can show is that the leakage
that you if you share the liquid will be
basically the summation of the network
effect that's caused by others plus some
terms that I call it user effect and
this is basically in terms of the sigma
I as well as this network effect okay so
I can write it additively and in
particular I can even show more so your
price you can actually write it in close
form so your price will be we said that
it is the difference of the information
leakage of whether you share or not
multiplied by the I so bi multiplied by
this value as we saw in the previous
slide where the information the network
effect actually can be characterized
completely based on the correlation
Matrix considering the agents that we
decided to share okay so if I fix the
action profile
this price that I should offer is
actually going to be completely
characterized in the closed form uh
setting okay so
um so that's good news because usually
in the if it was a networks we don't
have post form Solutions yes
should one interpret the variance of
each user
uh so the various
so I have some prior about you right I
would say that your data is coming from
a gaussian distribution and it has some
like it's going to right from an
informativeness point of view like is a
higher variance user more informative
less informative right if the variance
is higher so I'm looking at gaussian if
the variance is higher I know that's
about it the device is zero I completely
know your value
great but so then it's not valuable for
me as a platform right yeah if your
variance is zero yes it's less than
further yes yes
[Music]
I'm trying to decrease that brightness
right so if it's zero nothing to gain
that right
uh so
and now what we can see here is that
prices are increasing in Sigma I Square
this is what you were asking and also
prices are decreasing in the set of
users who will share the information
right because if more users are sharing
it's going to be depleted
now now let's actually go to the
inefficiency result so
um something that will be important for
the inefficiencies is to Define like
these two sets of low value users and
high value users so I will call the
users who have value less than one for
the Privacy low value and the rest high
value users
so
um one thing that you can see easily is
that all your all low value users are
going to share their value share their
data in the secondary equilibrium and
why is that because even if there was no
externality if it was nothing there is
still the platform was willing to buy it
right if it was just like they were
single Thrones sitting around the
platform still would buy them right now
with we know that with the externalities
the prices will be even lower so I will
buy them right so uh as a result in any
statelberg equilibrium uh all low value
users are going to be to share their
data now using this property
we can actually get some inefficiency
results so the first thing is that if
high value users are uncorrelated with
each other and with the low value users
then the equilibrium will be efficient
so that is good news
so this is the case that these are low
values and the correlation is already
happening here for high values there are
just single tones sitting around okay
however if there is a correlation
between the high value user and the low
value users then there is a threshold
for this value that if you pass that
threshold for the high value users then
you will have inefficiency
similarly
even if you don't as a high value user
if there is no correlation of high value
users with the low value users so they
have nothing to do with the low value
users and their correlations only among
themselves still there is a mid-range
for the values of the high value users
that if you are in that range we can
show that inefficiency happens and the
reason is this power bond is exactly
because of this externality properties
right because because they have
externality even though their value is
higher than one for the Privacy they
know that their information will be
leaked and as a result they are going to
share their information even though they
know that their utility will become
negative
foreign
it's negative but it becomes even worse
uh uh so
now the question is uh given these
things we want to see whether the data
markets are beneficial or in other words
is it better to shut down the data
market or keep it so that's the question
in as uh by beneficial that's what I
mean so what in order to understand that
let's actually put a simple bound on the
social surplus okay
so so the social surplus that we get
recall that the social surplus was one
minus v i times the information leakage
of each user summation over o i right so
if you are a low value user this term is
going to be a positive because 1 minus
VI is a positive thing so this term is a
positive thing so I will put the upper
bound on the information leakage to
maximize its uh magnitude right so uh
this is less than or equal to 1 minus v
i summation over I in the low value
users times the information leakage if I
assume everybody will share
and if you are looking at the high value
users I know that this term is negative
so basically if I want to find an upper
bound I'm going to minimize the
information leakage we know that all low
value users no matter what they're gonna
share so I'm going to put the VL here so
this is an upper bound on my social
surplus now
if this is negative this upper bound is
negative then it means that you're
actually having a negative Surplus in
the equilibrium or basically if you shut
down data market you're happier
you can write this in terms of The
Primitives and basically it will be if
there is a hard correlation uh with the
individuals in the low value side
as you can see it here and then uh
potentially you will get a negative
Surplus which means that if I shut down
the data market probably it will be
better for the society
uh okay so now I set this thing for a
very specific setting so I assume that
the information leakage has this like
the uh decrease in the in a square error
and also I assume the gaussian
distribution now
as long as you have those two properties
that I mentioned at the beginning the
monotonicity and submodularity
properties
uh all the results will hold so
basically what we built up is that we
showed that this submergillard property
hold for our uh information uh leakage
definition and then based on these two
properties we prove their results
similarly for the inefficiency results
we the main properties that we use is
these two so if you change these
notations and as long as you can show
that these two properties Hold Still You
will have those inefficiencies and also
the existence result our other examples
uh yeah so there was a the
the sort of information here to measures
that satisfied you know these two
properties as well not the Dutch
students yeah so reduction in entropy
okay so
uh now the setting that I said was I
have one platform and everything was
known so you can actually uh generalize
this then the platform does not know the
values and needs to design an incentive
compatible mechanism in order to also
learn the people value for their privacy
also if the correlation structure is not
known but there is a belief about it
again the result school and
similar results well when there are
competing platform but there is also one
more thing about the competition so
usually we expect that the competition
is going to improve the efficiency here
what we will see is that this is not
necessarily the case in fact it could
provide some extra causes for
inefficiency as we will see next
okay so I would not Define the utility
models again for the competition so it
will be the same we take a small
difference so here I will also have like
some value for joining because we think
that for example if a platform has more
users on it then probably it's in terms
of like the value of joining it's more
beneficial right so for example like if
there are two social networks one of
them has more users probably you prefer
to be on the one with ignoring the
privacy in terms of joining you will get
higher value there right so we are going
to consider a uh joining a value
function which is monotone in the set of
joint users and then now you have a two
things that you should decide about
whether you want to join this platform
on the other platform for now we assume
that each user will join either of the
platform so the value of joining is
higher than not joining and uh then uh
you are also going to decide about
whether you want to share your data or
not so you have two actions to think
about
so this and platforms are going to
simultaneously offer the prices and the
users are going to simultaneously make
their data sharing decision okay
so what we will show here is that
here it's actually this is an
interesting uh so with a with an
interesting example we actually showed
that a pure strategy equilibrium for
joining may not exist and uh however we
can look at the mixed strategy so we can
easily you can see that if you decide to
join each platform with probably one
half then this will be a mixed strategy
equilibrium for joining and the results
the results that I will explain is going
to be also hold if for example you have
information leakage between the two
platforms
so before I explain the theorem let me
actually give you another example so you
have two users with the correlated data
and suppose that the first user has a
value less than one and let's for now
assume that the joining value is a
constant so they you will have the same
joining value which is a high value
so if I have the second user if the
second user has a very very high value
so V2 if it is much higher than one
under Monopoly only user 1 will share
user 2 will not share right under
competition what will happen is that
users join different platforms user one
will share user 2 will not share and in
fact this is going to be improving the
Surplus right so you don't have that
damage of leakage from the person who
had a high value for the utility yes
something but is there a value to
Consumers for being on the same platform
there is a value so we call it C but for
now let's assume that this C is constant
so if you join the platform you will get
that value so either this platform or
the other one but in general you will
see the condition that we need to have
in order to enforce the efficiency
work effect so I don't care how many
other people are on the platform that
there could be a network effect so we
will actually support now let's assume
for the consent in this example but in
dilemma but in the theorem when I
explain it there will be a condition
which will will be based on the
externalities like the how increasing
the C function should be in terms of the
user's joint in order to get efficiency
that's what you want to get that I think
so yeah
uh so
uh so this is a good thing now suppose
that
the value of the second user is less
than one so now under the competition
what will happen is that again under
Monopoly both users will check because
both of them have value less than one
and uh we get a good Surplus with
competition again users will share but
they are going to join different uh
platforms and this is because of the
leakage that will happen if you share on
the same platform and the price uh
damage that you will have if you have
the on you're on the same platform so in
this case what I care about is the 1
minus UI times the information leakage
right so this one minus bi is positive
for both of the users and as a result
I'd like to increase this information
leakage because that will increase the
Surplus however since they're on
different platforms I do not get that
much right so as a result even the value
of the other one is also low here in the
competition I'm actually losing in terms
of the Surplus
okay so now this is the result so
suppose high value users again are
uncorrelated with the low value users in
the first case then the equilibrium is
efficient if and only if the increase in
the costs that you will get
uh for joining by like if the set is Big
the set of the users that are joining
are bigger is higher than some threshold
okay so basically if that joining has a
a higher slope right uh you are going to
actually have an efficiency result if it
is not the case you will have
inefficiency result
and now the other cases will be similar
to the previous uh case like the mono uh
the Monopoly case so suppose that there
is a high low correlation now again if
the value of the high users is higher
than some threshold you will have
inefficiency and uh in the third case
suppose that the high value users are
correlated with at least one another
high value users then if the values are
going to be in some mid-range again you
will reach out to the inefficiency so
basically what we will see is that I
added the competition I expected more
efficiency and now I have a harder
situation of uh getting that efficiency
so now the question is that what can we
do so basically you can either like if
you know the values and also the
structure so basically you can think
that I can give person a specific taxes
to the people uh to encourage them to
share and that's a typical movie on
taxes so this is not surprising that it
will improve the efficiency
but can we do something better than that
so the approach that is basically like
this is like something that needs to
actually know the complete structure of
the network so that's the caveat of the
approach uh not exactly the same
criticism that you just made of the
decentralized piguvian solution knowing
no it needs to know also the values
there I
just like I mean
I
mean
like if you say so
uh so you need to know the structure
here not the values okay so the one less
one level
so uh so now the approach is the
following so we call it the correlation
steam or whitening uh the noise right so
why basically what you're going to do is
that suppose that these are the signals
and what I will do is that I will
multiply by the signals the inverse
Matrix of the correlations right so the
covariance inverse multiplied by S this
will be the signals that are the output
okay so these will be the signal that I
will let the platform share and this
mediator should be somebody who actually
you trust and will do this for you
now uh with this the correlation scheme
what you can see is that
x i and S inverse
the S hat minus I have zero correlations
and exactly because of the structure of
that and then x i and S hat I are fully
correlated okay so basically
what it means is that
um for those who are sharing their data
will be as before their data will be
their correlation will be uh kept and
for those who decide not to share it's
like that you are dropping the edges for
them right so you would only keep the
correlation among those who are sharing
their data that's the implication of
this uh whitening noise so as a result
with the correlation uh scheme the
information leakage of an agent I will
be what if it would be zero if nobody
share if you decide not to share and if
you decide to share it would be
basically the information leakage of
those people who shared among similar to
before right
so
um I think this is a good property
because you are dropping The Unwanted
edges you are dropping for those who are
not uh willing to share you are dropping
their edges to their people this is the
property of this scheme so now what we
can show is that uh with this scheme the
social surplus is always positive and
also it's going to be better than the
previous always better than the previous
equilibrium social surplus and
um High values users never contribute
negative values that's the property and
low value users are going to be
contributing positively and negative
externalities are going to be smaller
here so
we cannot show whether it guarantees the
first best so if that uh so we could not
prove that thing
um and in fact I think we have examples
that we do not get the first best uh so
it's not still giving us the first best
so uh with that said so uh basically in
this talk I wanted to talk about some
like basic model of like data market to
see like first step of how to study
different properties of it and what we
saw is that when you have externalities
the data the prices will be depressed
and uh the other thing that would be
very interesting to know is what sort of
in like intervention and regulations we
should do in order to get more efficient
data markets so there are many things to
be done here this was just like one
first step too like a trial on the data
market
if you have any questions I would be
happy you have time for one question
since we're overtime but yeah
so let's see include like some of this
Facebook I don't think this is feasible
for every example but if you include the
uh if you increase the number of
observations in a data set it would have
been true that that will intensify the
sub modularity and if you actually could
learn more and more observations that we
have the prices of zero yeah yeah
so again different depends on the
information the definition but I think
for our case yes I think there is a much
larger property rule so as you share
more and more it's like that you have
like fully correlated data that is like
shared
but multiple so you can think that you
are adding like single tones that are
like you right and shared every time so
I think with a similar uh proof it has a
sub modular property yes and the prices
will be depleted to zero in that case
okay great so now we have a break until
the level 15 and we'll be complete at 11
15 for more